so I guess two preparatory notes one I
speak really fast so feel free I'll try
to slow down but feel free to wave at me
if I'm going too fast or interrupt me
and ask questions on second I at one
level said a little bit here this is a
this talk is like about our
communication security which involves
cryptography in kind of the same way
that plumbing you know involves
hydrodynamics namely you know we use it
but we don't really understand it and we
just sort of treat it like a building
block but so you don't really need ever
cm brain watching about cryptography to
make sense at this make sense when I'm
talking about but you do understand what
the basic things do so as a level set
like how many people recognize the word
RSA okay diffie-hellman signatures max
fantastic well I'm just gonna mostly
presume you know that stuff seriously
like the most telling dr. Serban a
earlier just just two minutes ago on the
striking thing about what's sort of gone
wrong over the years of TLS is how
little of it actually depends on
understanding cryptography and how much
depends on understanding sort of logic
of how the systems were put together and
what the building blocks actually do as
opposed to sort of breaking the curve
graphic primitives though there have
been pieces of that too so here is sort
of my schedule for what I plan to talk
about I'm gonna go over sort of the
background of TLS and give it a short
induction to some of how TLS the current
version of TLS works and then talk about
some of the problems we've actually
encountered actually we started doing
that interstitially so I'll introduce a
feature and talk about how some of the
problems we've had are on the idea here
to motivate a why we're doing something
new and B to give you a sense that the
kind of things that go wrong and the
rationale for how we're trying to do
better this time and why we're in why
some of the decisions we made or B have
been made on then I want to talk about
the objectives for sale 7.3 which is the
version we're currently working on show
you what tell some point there looks
like and then finally it's bend the
slider to talking about where we are and
how we planning before word so what does
TL as I was writing this I was
distressed to realize how long I've been
working on this technology which is now
over 20 years which is really kind of
depressing at some level I was
not anyway the original designer of this
on the version that we are using now so
tell us was introduced basically by
netscape back in the previous prehistory
of the web when as was suggested earlier
they needed something to do security and
they ended it very fast and the basic
design criterion was we would like to be
able to have people buy stuff over the
internet and put their credit cards into
the browser and that was the main thing
people cared about on the idea people
had in their heads was that this was
going to be like UNIX sockets but it was
going to secure and at the time it was
called secure socket layer so there were
sort of several very early versions of
SSL on starting with SSL v1 which never
really made out of the lab SSL v2 which
was relatively widely deployed but had a
number of problems the version were
using now is this thing called is so the
thing that basically superseded SLB 2
was SSL version 3 which is largely
similar to tell us now and that was
designed sort of relatively short time
by Netscape by some people in that scape
in order to fix the perceived problems
SSL version 2 and that got very wide
deployment and then was standardized by
ATF with the usual sort of modest
modifications in the service of both
improvements and not invented here so
even tell us one goes back to bat I
think 1998 at this point in SL version 3
goes back to bat ninth because backed
about 95 so at this point on to give the
people do this work credit they said
we're gonna build something with
security over for TCP and that is true
we're going to be an incredibly powerful
primitive because so many things are
never TCP and just having a secure
channel abstraction is very powerful and
so now it's used for almost anything you
can think of then initial designs were
for HTTP but it's used for VPNs it's
used for email both for sending and for
retrieval on it's used for Internet of
Things communication it's even used on
for doing security for voice and video
there's now a version of TLS called
Datagram TLS which basically is the same
concept over UDP that's what's that's
part of what's used for voice of video
on that sometimes I'm an ulcer priority
so as I said Netscape were the original
people that did this but it got taken
over by the internet Engineering Task
Force or contributed and then picked up
and since then their base
we've been three versions of TLS version
one which I said was their first
introversion 1.1 which is like a trivial
change and 1.2 which was done in
response to the work about I guess but
almost 8 years ago now breaking md5 and
sha-1 when everybody was terrified
they're all our hash functions were
going to be destroyed on
so when sov 3 was just shipped it
basically assumed you had md5 and sha-1
and what we wanted to do is make it
worker sought to in sha 3 and whatever
so it turned out to be a lot harder to
do that to me actually would've thought
because things are more brittle than you
think so as I said on TLS and SSL
presented this secure channel
abstraction and the basic model that
almost everybody is operating under is
this the client knows he wants to talk
to you the client has a domain name for
the server and the server does not get
to know who the client is so the client
says I want to catch this website and
that although in principle there are
mechanisms in TLS for the client to
fennec 8 to the server in practice those
get a fair amount of use but nowhere
near as much use as the basic mode that
almost every web browser uses which is
the client connect to the server and the
client doesn't offender care at all and
if a client wants to authenticate then
they attend a--quite by typing a
password into some webpage which then
gets sent over the secure and the reason
this is supposed to be safe is because
the browser verify that you were talking
to Gmail and therefore whatever they're
typing it is going to Gmail on once this
is done then all the data is encrypted
and authenticated and so the guarantee
from the clients perspective is supposed
to be that everything I send is only
going to the server and everything I get
back from the server was secured in
transit and really came from the server
lower than somebody else and the
guarantee from the server's perspective
is a little fuzzier which is the same
person that sent me the sort of initial
block of data is now sending a later
block of data but I don't really know
who you are and so you know if there's a
password so hopefully the password I'm
getting and the request to retrieve
email from the same guy that's the
guarantee you're supposed to be getting
but again you don't know that or if you
don't tentacle TLS has this sort of
structure back when SSL entails were
designed there was a raft of sort of
secure protocols being designed SSH and
IPSec and a bunch of other stuff and
all sort of converged after once a fall
starts in the same basic structure which
is there's some handshake protocol which
is typically pretty fancy and the
handshake particles job is to actually
negotiate they hit the key material so
you want to establish a shared key
between the client the server you want
to negotiate the algorithms the modes
the parameters but this typically means
is like what key exchange you're using
what encryption algorithm using that
kind of stuff and you want to finicky
one or both sides it said in TLS that
largely means the server but an IPSec or
SSH it might mean both the client and
the server and so the vast majority of
complexity in TLS is that chunk is the
handshake
once that handshake is done there's also
a record protocol which actually carries
the data from the clot from the client
to the server and vice versa which is
comparatively simple though even that
we've seen problems with or didn't
provide the advertised security
guarantees and I have a little bit of
control about that later on
like all like basically all these
systems the initial handshake uses
public key cryptography uses it
diffie-hellman use elliptic curve
diffie-hellman use RSA something like
that and the record protocol but that
just negotiates a key and the record
protocol uses some sort of symmetric
cryptography these days typically AES or
ChaCha
okay you don't need that this was just
there in case people don't know what
that what I was talking about so this
slide here shows basically the hands a
skeleton for essentially the basic TLS
1.2 handshake which is almost identical
to ta this level abstraction is
identical to the TLS is over your 3
handshake so this is what you would this
is what people did for like a very very
long time until almost all time until
basically probably the fact last 5 years
perhaps been past three years perhaps so
the client opens up with this client
holo-message which contain which is the
most important thing for now is it
contains a random nonce and like all
these so one column called we could
graph reporter calls his replay problems
replay attacks so the random nonce
serves to guarantee to the client that
anything the server that the server's
messages refresh the server responds
with his own random nonce and with a
certificate and the certificate ties in
this case is RSA public key to his
identity so at this point the client can
in principle
you can't validate he's actually talking
to the server but he can validate at
least that there's some credential of
binds an RSA public key to the claim
that any of the server until the server
this first message the server is done
doesn't require knowing the private key
the client only knows that there's
someone out there with this identity
then as I said the on the client then
generate some random value on in this
gate what's called the master secret
which is basically a random 48 bit 48
byte string not 48 bit that would be bad
and in ciphers it under the server's RSA
public key and sends it to the server
and then follows up with a back over the
entire handshake with the master secret
is the key for that Mac and it's quite a
cool that's called a finished message so
the guarantee the client obviously as at
this point is only the true server
should be able to decrypt this message
and so when the server responds with his
own Mac over the handshake then the the
client knows he's now talking to free
server at least theoretically because
anybody else couldn't have reconstructed
the key material to generate the master
secret on also the convention I'm using
here is anything that Alex is encrypted
so these messages are also encrypted so
as a practical matter the server
couldn't even read the finished message
and you couldn't have sent a finished
messing with your validate historically
until pretty recently TLS has use
composite cipher modes by which I mean
you use AES and you'd use HTML 1 and you
put them together
TLS is now moving very aggressively
towards on a EAD authenticated
encryption the additional data cipher
modes on that don't have better security
guarantees at least we know these two
under implementation parameters so once
you've done that stuff as I said you can
look at the bulk of this and just the
wait for times as much data in the sort
of my stuff going on in the handshake is
going application data and that's
probably actually about right in terms
of how big the protocol is so once
you've done that you start sending up
okay she data back and forth so would
the life were that simple already life
is more complicated so the client and
the server have diverse capabilities and
one thing that's actually worked pretty
well is when tls/ssl were first rolled
out people had des and triple des and
now we have aes and ChaCha and stuff
like that and we've made that transition
pretty smoothly without breaking anybody
which is actually quite good so we've
also gone through several versions of
protocol without breaking anybody too
badly which is also pretty good on this
mean
oh okay okay great um so there's more
stuff in here the on the client has this
version number so you can do version
negotiation the client offers a bunch of
cipher suites and what's in a cipher
suite is on is basically the curtain
graphic characters you want to use so
there's a key change algorithm is
signature algorithm and a bulk
encryption algorithm and a Mac although
these days there was last to become an
AED algorithm
it's also possible negotiate compression
um that turned out to have been a bad
plan and we're taking that out I'll talk
about that very briefly and somewhere
along the way between SSL v3 and version
two someone decided to be good for the
client to be able to send arbitrary
stuff in his client holo on in case you
want to say some things which this
grammar didn't let you say and so
basically get to send a pile of
extensions and the extensions just TLV
pairs I'll come back to that a little
bit
so the basic model that Ellis has always
followed that goes back to SSL version
on three is the client Walker has a
bunch of stuff and the server choose
that at a list so pretty much everything
you saw the client offered a list of the
server gets to choose one he chooses one
cipher suite just one compression method
and then the extensions exe that goes
stuff um but I haven't talked with a
session ID I'll get to that in a minute
right so this slide is redundant the
Cypress wait contains basically all the
parameters you want to use there's been
a huge split and protocol design by the
way in terms of taste about whether you
should do individual selection for each
of these or whether you should do a
suite that contains all of them and both
of these turned I peek terrible
approaches the individual selection you
can't actually mix and match because it
turns out lots of things aren't
compatible with other things and so you
have like some hardware security module
which can like sign stuff we want
algorithm but then you have to use
another algorithm for key exchange on or
over hashing um and conversely if you do
sweet to get comments or explosions so
now these things works very well
like IPSec did Chinese menu and tell us
does comet or explosion those are the
two main options so
so I'm certain that much that was
inductor II I want talk a little bit
about how things have gone wrong over
the years so I'm gonna give a couple
examples of till those features are
turned out not to be as awesome as you
might have hoped so TLS has what
superficially seemed like this very
elegant mechanism for renegotiating so
the idea would be I've set up a TLS
connection to you and for some reason
I'm sad about the parameters and they're
a bunch of reasons that might be sad one
reason I might be sad is I've been
encrypting for the past month with the
same keys and I might think it's time
for new keys this is a lot more of an
issue if you're using like des than if
you're using a yes there would still an
issue with AES because you could only
encrypt maybe you know two to the 32
blocks before people start to fall apart
so tell us had as I say what appear to
be the super very superficially elegant
mechanism where you could just on again
everything that's italic is encrypted so
you could simply take the initial
handshake and then you could renegotiate
by offering a new handshake over the
encrypted connection and that and the
client server pick up where they left
off so this seems like not bad idea and
it works pretty well um sometimes
there's a bit of confusion about what
the status of the data is if it isn't
relieved between some of these handshake
messages the made people kind of sad and
in fact the discussion on the tailless
Mellon's right now about how to treat
that but that's not the part that made
people sad it turns out um the part that
made people sad is this now if you look
at the date
you'll notice the TLS was designed
around 94 and this was discovered in
2010 so as I was saying earlier um then
there's anything about this is you don't
even know anything about cryptography at
all understand what the problem is here
you just have to see the problem and
someone finally saw the problem so the
problem is really quite simple which is
that remember I said that we just do a
new handshake over the old connection
well there's nothing that connects the
old connection in the new connection and
so it's possible to a situation where
the sides are confused about how many
connections there again so the basic
attack looks like guest the attacker
um so we always we just always assume a
network attacker that can do anything it
wants or the packets so the attacker
makes their own connection to the server
and on and does the hotel's connection
remember the attacker like in general
for HTTP
so the attacker does their own
connection absolutely as ordinary to the
server and then what they do is they
stuff their own message down the channel
they send like a get and I wish that era
wasn't bi-directional but there it is so
they send like the beginning of an HTTP
request but not the end of an HTTP
request so they have the server version
of warm and the server sort of reading
this and the server is ready to keep
reading and then what they do is they
take the clients connection and they
intercept it and they take the clients
TLS connection and they just proxy it
over their own encrypted channel to the
server and at this point the client of
the server have an encrypted connection
which the attacker can't read on that's
okay because there another neo yet and
then the first in the client does is
attends own HTTP request on the channel
so you're suing I'm assuming web here
and somewhere in that HTTP request is
his cookie and so and you know if you do
this exactly right then you get the
right number of curl ifs and this looks
like it's all one big request
we've won like malformed header line
which is that which is the clients get
and so now what the Tigers managed to do
is he managed to splice his own request
on to the clients event occasion
credentials and gets at that example I
wish I'd used post here but if that
request has any side-effects then he's
basically convinced the client to do
something for him that he would not
otherwise have done this is bad so the
server client the Tigers didn't get an
arbitrary prefix out of the clients
clients connection one thing you'll find
by the way is a lot of these attacks are
attacks that don't look very good in
traditional network environments because
it's hard for instance if this is like a
telnet connection or it's a on satellite
connection or it's like an eye NAP
connection it's hard to sort of convince
the clients to generate the data you on
the jet to generate but in web
connections is really often very easy
because the attacker gives an enormous
amount of control over what the client
actually does and so that the third
crucial thing you'll do is you'll make
your own web page that points to the
victims web page and now you can
synthesize ulcers we'll stop and get the
client to do it for you
so the advent of the web has actually
made this much I made this threatened
all and much more serious and if you
look at a number of the attacks that we
seen recently Leon tell us they
basically depend on the attacker having
pretty tight control users web browser
but that's okay because you can get that
kind of tight control quite easily
but the only really worked because of
that environment right so this is fine
um this is bad for on the client and the
server can't tell the server thinks is a
renegotiation and the server may wanted
the renegotiation so let me do this
first I'll go back so the first thing we
the first idea we had when this came up
with let's just turn off renegotiation
we won't let anybody renegotiate that's
not the world's worst idea but it turns
out that the thing reasons you need
renegotiation and the most important one
of these first two which is considering
the client certificate and post
handshake line authentication so I don't
think I'm not sure I have a slide that
shows client authentication but until
it's one point to the client certificate
is set in the clear it's not sent
encrypted and so that means that the any
network attacker can see the client
certificate and see the client is which
obviously has bad privacy problems so
it's attractive the nice thing about
this reason ago she Asian technique is
if this second handshake were like a
legitimate handshake then the client
certificate will be encrypted to be
encrypted by the first connection so
that would be good on the other reason
why people wanted to often want to do
this is you have to often have settings
where only part of a website is
protected so you have a website which is
which is a fennec aided by client fen
occation and the client so the client
will surf around the website for a while
and then eventually it hits a protected
resource and then only then will the
server one interrogate the client for
certificate and this is made even worse
by the fact that the you are UI is in
the browser to really really bad about
client certificates and so it's
incredibly invasive death ask the client
for a certificate and so servers avoid
it like at all costs and so the point
being that if you have one these
multi-level sites what you want to do is
let the client serve for a while and
only then enforce a renegotiation this
is gonna be a problem later we'll get to
so the fix for this once you know about
this the fix for this doesn't seem too
bad um basically made it on me to new it
many if it meant many the situation we
find ourselves in by the way are that we
had this really quite complicated
apparatus and we find things we didn't
like and we say what's the minimal
change we can make to repair this
particular problem
and maybe some problems around it but
totally redesigning everything is that
furniture really expensive as well as
we're seeing now so the minimal fix for
this may be slightly more in the middle
effects but a modestly minimal fix for
this is to add new extension the
client-server holo and the way this
works is that basically you echo these
Mac's from the previous on the previous
handshake in the new handshake and so
what happens obviously is in the case
here the server thinks he's got a Mac
from the from this first hand shape or
the client tells it as you get a
handshake failure so that looks like it
works pretty well though it turns out
that for other reasons this runs into
problem so later though it took again
about four years to find that so good
right so I wish I'd done this the office
order this is what I was talking about
earlier which is to say that the clients
suffer go along just fine he asked for
some secure resource and then this or
burgers oh now I need your certificate
and he plumps him and the way the server
does that by the way is this hello
request message which says please start
a new handshake with me Wow I'm at least
a minute backslash shouldn't it okay um
so in order to understand how this fixed
and not act exactly put as a desired
outcome you have to understand one more
feature about TLS which is the thing
called session resumption so back when
this stuff was designed public key
operations about which I mean like RSA
was incredibly expensive and it was the
bottleneck for building any kind of
secure server and so when the system was
built they designed a system that would
allow you to amortize one public key
exchange over multiple connections this
is called presumption and the basic idea
is like super simple okay that I'm not
one okay okay okay
so the basic idea was like really it was
really simple that on your initial
connection when you used when you used
RSA or diffie-hellman but back then it
was RSA that the server would give you
an identifier and when you came back
you'd say I know about to identify err
and the server would like look it up in
his table and go I have the key so it
looks like this stuff and red is new so
the client connects this is the new
handshake the client connects to the
server and he says here's my session ID
the services fantastic here's the
session ID and I wish there wasn't a
certificate there because it doesn't
belong there but at this point your
encrypted and you're good to go
oh this is very icy this is very
embarrassing that's what I wanted um
this is the slide so right so the
initial handshake will set this I
thought I had going one slide the
district looks like this which is the
new section ID is saying this is what it
is and in the and then the resumption
looks like this so there's no no public
encrypt out so this is obviously a huge
event huge performance improvement and
and and if you go back and look at the
stuff that the work that was done when
Telos first came out you seen lots of
measurements that basically show here's
what your web server will do if you
don't have resumption here's like what
it will do if you do a presumption and
it's just a total no-brainer there's no
way there's no way any sane person would
not run this and in fact it's such a
no-brainer that there was a bunch of
later work done partly done partly here
Stanford with on precipitation Holcomb
on on all flowed on figuring out how to
remove these servers need to store the
database of session IDs by also in the
date of the client because it's so
attractive to have this kind of
optimization however it turns out that
this does not make the world necessarily
as much better as you're hoping so this
very nice work on came out of an RIA
back in 204 on this thing called a
triple handshake so the background here
is the is in Rio guys I'm Karthik
Bhagavan and other people have built
this fully verified TLS implementation
at a called me TLS that is written in I
want to say f-sharp and they actually
have a formal proof of it and so
somewhere along the way they discover
their proof isn't going through and they
find this so the first thing is
straightforward and was already known
for a while which is that it's possible
for an attacker to force two TLS
connections at the same King material
and the way this works is that if you're
doing RSA then if you're connecting the
attacker you just give the attacker the
key you want to use and the attacker can
make his own connection to the server
and give that server the same key and
the only diversification in the
handshake is the random messages but the
Tigers would echo those and so you end
up with the same king material and this
has been known for a very long time
interestingly what wasn't known is it's
also possible to diffie-hellman if
you're not careful and that was sort of
new but so many queries where I say that
wasn't that wasn't
again sir so these cases had the same
extra secret but the fashion else was
serious ordinarily because look you're
connecting the attacker the autocracy is
a date he gets anything he wants the
server and having and and having and so
he could have said anything you wanted
to you anyway
where did this get serious is when you
connect it with resumption so the client
disconnects to make it a new connection
and he makes the connection apparently
he thinks the attacker but the attacker
proxies the data to the server and now
he has a connection with and because the
keys are the same and the session IDs
are the same now he's at to connection
with it as a connection with a surfer
but is actually the server that he knew
the attacker also knows the keys for and
what the attacker does is he does
exactly the same thing I just showed you
with the rehan shake he sends his own
request because he knows the key he's
down the channel for the secure resource
and then he gets out of the way and lets
the server request free negotiation at
this point the server and the client we
negotiate and at this point the client
sends a certificate and he signs the
handshake and on the clients that
indicated the server he thinks is a
fennec aid to the attacker but he's
actually at that Nick aid to the server
on and so this is not good I think we
can agree so on that was unfortunate
so this basically resurrects the
resurrects the the renegotiation attack
on as Karthik points out the targets
controller quest but he gets the he gets
the attack declined to do something on
his behalf with a server on so again
unfortunate on the fix for this and you
can see it sort of slowly backing into
the TLS 1.3 design here is the problem
is you might think the problem is the
resumption but the problem is not the
problems no key sure in the first
handshake and the fix for this is to
stop is to make it not possible to have
two TLS handshakes from different people
with the same keying material and so the
fix that the bhagavad all proposed is to
take the server certificate and in fact
take the entire handshake transcript up
to the point of key exchange and digest
that into the keying material so that
basically that ties the master key into
the server's identity so you can't have
two professions or two people with the
same different identities and the same
keys unless well at all
as long as your rent as long as your
numbers are fresh but as long as they
have different identities unless you
break the hash of course and because the
session resumed handshake is connected
to has the same key material from the
initial handshake that inherits that
inherits the certificate and so the
binding continues so to deploy because
you gotta change all browsers are
interchangeable sir yes so these say to
play yes in place actually somewhat
depressing which is that renegotiate the
fix for renegotiation has only gotten
wide deployment fairly recently and the
fix for triple handshake is literally
region is in a non is in a what
alpha version of Firefox now so yes it's
not fantastic and it takes one time to
fix these things and the worst part and
I get this in a second is that it's not
clear what you do as a client when you
encounter somebody who doesn't support
these things so the way this case
negotiate is you have an extension that
says please like you know do the second
hash thing and what do you do when you
run into somebody doesn't it doesn't
that's where that extension does not
that's problematic sir it's a little bit
based on this right what are these sort
of I can't tell what I can't tell if
it's good or bad but one of the sort of
odd things about working in this field
is you get these very very nice pieces
of work that show that the protocols are
badly are badly damaged in some way or
another or maybe badly badly maybe not
badly damaged and then you never hear
about anybody exploit in them and so we
don't know we don't know is I mean I
mean someone someone demos it I don't
mean that it's not it doesn't work I
mean someone will show you a demo but
you never hear well I was going to
Amazon and here someone bought some
stuff on you know using my use my credit
card number I don't actually even answer
this my my glib answer is that
everything else is it's not so much
worse shape that this is not the easiest
way to go after it
these can be useless stuff so so neither
of these attacks is a fantastic attack
on the kind of things I would probably
want it I'm not an intelligence agency
but on the kind of things you'd probably
want to do if your intelligence agency
was there mostly about authentication
rather than about confidentiality um
some of the some of the attacks didn't
publish for the past few years on
confidentiality of TLS are things you
might imagine intelligence agents
deploying sir for instance the freak
attack on large Emmett at that came out
earlier this year or the or or
alternately perhaps the lucky 13 work
Kenny Patterson data Holloway so some of
you think there are there are attacks
that our confidentiality threats on
other things you would imagine
intelligence agencies are playing in
many cases the problem is they're active
attacks so the good news about this by
the way I should be clear the good news
is that almost all these attacks are
active attacks and so that doesn't mean
that you can't deploy them in the wild
but it means that if you can deploy them
at scale in the wild you may have some
side effects that people with people
notice and so it's not like we have a
bunch of passive attacks that are really
easy to on the play which is again I
don't really don't want to say that it's
not possible people deploying this on in
the field it's just that it's not
trivial oh the other thing of course
worth noting is our defenses aren't very
good in terms of detecting stuff so
maybe possible that these attacks around
all time we simply have no idea the
infrastructure well so to give an
example of perhaps one where one would
be difficult about an active attack
there's this lucky 13 attack on the
Kenny Patterson's group did where that
relied on getting the client to send the
same day to the server over and over and
over again right so you could mount an
attack like that but the consequence
would be that the users machine is gonna
generate a lot of X traffic and they
might notice that under some
circumstances so some of the tasks are
more detectable others
Dave from the time the specification
became stable you said you're now
starting to get a reasonable amount of
deployment use calendar time roughly
when the tears okay second question is
you made reference to client
yes the server and my impression has
been that on the average Tillis has been
used for client authentication only a
tiny amount comparable yes if that's
starting to change how and when and by
whom right so there are on there are a
couple settings in which client
indication is widely deployed
enterprises do it quite often I mean so
first of all you're absolutely right the
vast majority of TLS is one way of
indicating server only the settings in
which it which is deployed on widely are
these enterprise settings on and also
starting to deploy more on WebRTC and
stuff like that where you want mutual
authentication that aren't really
classic client server settings they're
just settings that happen to be
client-server but it's absolutely the
case that that this is a smaller on a
smaller set of things it's worth noting
that the renegotiation info attack offer
does not depend that's that works
against classic client indication even
with even with passwords which is
incredibly common so this this works
primarily with certificate verification
because the in this case the attacker
could have convinced you to give you to
give him your password in any case he
didn't need that on blood because the
the client thinks is talking to attacker
not to not to the out of the victim but
on the other one client side and the
server side with all these these pads
that are not supposed to exist
you see you seem to be concentrating on
this spec what might you do in 1.3
demise the vast amounts of it should be
there thank you for that thank you for
pointing that so yes we are removing a
point where you're removing a pile of
stuff so so kailasam point three has
become more complicated in terms of well
perhaps it is a protocol but I mean in
terms of an effort size and we initially
envisioned
but the objectives remain the same the
first objective was to clean things up
by which I mean rue a bunch of stuff
which either unsafe or it's not widely
used or both and there's some matrix of
how unsafe is it versus how widely used
is it to try to improve the security of
the system and I think this goes two
ways one is by 20 improves specification
and the other is by making things enough
simple or that you could you have a
better shot at doing an implementation
that would be it would be secure not
sure I want to vouch for how about how
are we done on that second half of it
definitely trying on as I said earlier
the privacy properties have Telus 1 2 or
action out fantastic and things have and
people's view of how much you should
encrypt has sort of gotten more
aggressive over the past 20 years the
other thing that sort of relevant is the
TLS performance used to concentrate in
CPU and CPUs have gotten very very fast
and cryptographic algorithms gotten much
faster comparatively with especially
with the rise of elliptic curve
cryptography but the speed of light
unfortunately has not gotten any faster
and despite a lot of effort we haven't
made much progress in that so so
minimizing the number of round trips has
become um has become a very important
property and there's been a lot of work
on that over the years some of it here
and finally the unfortunate part about
this is we have a lot of important use
cases which we can't throw over so we
would like to have a world in which
people stop using TLS 1.2 and start
using Tayla 2.3 and if we take any large
set of use cases that people actually
the rely on and we abandon those then
we'll have a bifurcated world where
there's 1.2 or 1.3 and we constantly
fixing 1.2 and so there has to be there
has to be a balance between trying to
and then this is where what complexity
unfortunately comes in actually a
balance between maintaining all use
cases the people really really care
about so that they will convert while
also trying to trim off all the stuff
that's dangerous maneuvers they wish
they wouldn't use yes an SSL at least
there was all the computation was put on
the servers yes and there were DDoS
attacks that gloves done yes
all right has that changed and are you
planning to move more of the computation
to the client so we're currently pushes
more the computation on the client just
because the crypto math it's not a
deliberate design decision I
the way it happens to be the there's
been a bunch of discussion about other
anti-ddos measures primarily on premiere
and he does measures don't like involve
puzzles and stuff like that and hard to
know how tha's gonna really work then
the bottom line is most these systems
unless you do something explicit
something explicit it's pretty easy for
the client to generate garbage and force
the server to do something or other um
and that's true with almost any protocol
which doesn't explicit kind of puzzle
solving kind of thing and the difficulty
with those is a they didn't have very
unpleasant differential differential
impacts on you know little devices
versus fast devices and the other issue
is they tend to add round trips because
you because you I mean if you look at
when I show you tale some way three
hands I've become obvious that the
server is asked to do something I'm the
very first message and that something is
expensive and the only way and the and
there's no real way for him to verify
the clients done anything before hands
the only way for him to basically push
back on the client is to force a client
to eat a round-trip in order to solve
some puzzle and so that cuts into
performance desires but yes we have
talked about it on their thing is
frankly it's just the the degree to
which the kryptos gotten so fast has
really kind of pushed back on people's
concerned that computational dus if you
Adam Langley had this very nice talk on
a velocity few years ago about deploying
tell us at Google and how little impact
it had in their infrastructure to do so
people who's kind of has gotten bored
about the whole performance thing the
whole the whole TP performance thing
unless a it doesn't matter at all there
are still places where it matters but
it's a much lower impact thing than it
used to be worth the dominant cost so we
have a bunch of things which we took out
and algorithm reasonably quickly the
biggest one the one that actually kind
of hurts people hear is static RSA on so
for a very long time TLS had exactly
popper you're talking about where was
RSA only largely there was
diffie-hellman EC dat and there was
building news links were too expensive
and um that a was very spencer for the
server and b had lousy lousy PFS
properties by which i mean none namely
the server's private key were revealed
basically it was game over
so we've - so that was bad and the other
thing was it was kind of messing up the
handshake in terms of now you had to
support both vhe and RSA modes so
that out entirely their thing we took
out on is till you support this thing
that we were calling custom and
difficult groups I'm going to me by that
is it allowed the server to basically
make up some difficult group and just
tell the client to use it instead of
using one of the well-known groups like
the NIST groups and this is true this is
definitely true this was the dot the
only way you could run finite fields at
the Elmen about which I mean I mean you
could go you could certainly use a group
of someone else's generated but there
was no way to say use group thirty-two
you had to actually give the client the
entire group and it was possible with EC
but ah but it was possible you see to
use custom groups but nobody did it on
both because we want to peel the move
Dec and we wanted to be the handshake
smaller and because they were concerned
about because and because the triple
handshake attack on diffie-hellman
actually used a carefully constructed
bad group we thought it'd be a good idea
not to allow not till all the server's
specify their own group and so so TLS
now beta Tillis one point three will
only allow you to use a small set of
groups which are defined so we so we
sort of
the concern that pushes back on this is
you say well if you have a small number
of groups that makes an attractive
target for pre-computation attacks and
the I think we have two basic answers to
that that a that we do way that and
decided this is anyway and the true
basis of reasons were one that we would
like to put a little much larger
diffie-hellman group so we don't specify
any finding field group low 2048 so that
that pushes back that makes that makes
it much harder DeMint those kinds of
attacks because you have much stronger
group and the second is you want to push
people towards DC and we don't think
it's good idea field attorney thrown EDC
groups is that correct okay thank you I
didn't know that um
so on and so we won't field use a very
small number of EC groups on TLS one
three basic specifies recommends a total
of four EC groups
on P 256 p3 for 245 509 and goldilocks 4
for 8 which is the new two new curves
specified by CFR G so we don't want to
encourage people to invent their own on
the EC groups compression what I said
was kind of harmful removing negotiation
but then we had to sort of add back in
the special accommodation rooms talk
back and then it there been a series of
increasingly dangerous series of attacks
on these composite cipher modes partly
because TLS used an odd cipher
construction an odd composite mode
construction where it mapped and then
encrypted rather a encrypted then macked
and so we just in order to simplify the
system and to avoid concerns about this
we just swap those out entirely and all
we're specifying is a EAD which in
practice means Galla counter mode or
cha-cha poly 13 on to the other five and
we've also on rejigger the resumption
quite a bit so I don't think I need to
rationalize why we did this so I'm not
going to rationalize this for a minute
so there was this nice pit there's a
nice paper the beast on the climate
action how to exploit compression so the
general property is that and there's a
great example as I was saying of where
the web environment is particularly
dangerous
so there's nice attacks showing that the
attacker control part of the data on the
wire and they didn't know some of the
other day on the wire they could use
compression to determine what the other
date on the wire was and the basic idea
is that you have some target event data
and insurance like a cookie or a
password and you inject some data which
you know which has a hot widget which
you want to see how much redundancy it
has Visa Visa cookie or the password and
if you get a lot of comfort and look at
the output ciphertext ties and if you've
got a lot of compression then you've got
some good indication that you've got
redundancy if you get bad compression
then you're probably off and you keep
iterating over and over again until and
until you actually back out the cookie
or the password and it turns out that so
as I said this is an example where the
web environments particularly hazardous
because the attacker has the ability to
implant jobs within the client and make
the client do these things over and over
and over again with different input
different inputs like plain texts so
nobody really knows how to do this
safely and generically
that's a great open research problem if
anybody has an answer to how to use
compression encryption together
so we've done I do the same generically
and the whole point of TLS is to provide
generic mechanisms so we just taken this
out entirely
as a sidenote HDB - recently
standardized their own compression
mechanism for headers but it's
incredibly limited and doesn't do a very
good job of a compression compared to
what the state of the art is but only
least a very small amount of information
roughly what it is it's a replica is it
only finds where exact replicas so if
you have like exactly the same header
over and over again it works but if you
have things thrown off by one plus some
work at all so you don't comes
compression and put on your hand it
makes it much harder to attack this this
keeps coming up by the light we had just
about two months ago someone asking has
to put compression back in again and
being yelled down on so in a feeble that
perhaps feeble attempt to stamp
compression out even in 1.2 TLS went
through implications are forbidden to
offer compression even if they do 1.2
and they're required to choke if anybody
offers compression to them so we're kind
of hoping that people stop using this in
1.2 - people already get to be turned it
people always trying to turn it off in
browsers so I work for Mozilla we think
a lot about browsers but browsers are
also the dominant cost were almost all
the bandwidth and CPU on TLS goes it's
not that people you feel for the things
it's just that browsers are so big on
and people already started turning this
off in browsers because it because are
terrified of it so a little hole won't
have a big impact but we some small
subpopulation is to do use compression
these people were crowd will come on get
hosts I don't think I need to explain
why you're moving on EAD
I don't think I need explain this either
oh we also removed
TLS 1.3 allowed you to new goofy 8-point
formats so you could have uncompressed
point so you could have compress the
points we're two different kinds of
point compression depending on which
kind of group you had and so we removed
that entirely so yeah now you can only
have them compress points we doesn't
anybody ever really cared about
so yeah what's the reasoning for this on
the TLS implementations already but
essentially only support on compress
points that was the mandatories need to
have and the on so there wasn't a lot of
hope people were gonna move to compress
points only compress points
and then also that mean you had to do
post compress and uncompress because you
always have to support uncompressed and
so we figured you might as well keep
rather than the graduation was bad I
keep yelling the president round was
easier and um we are for all the new
groups there to 509 and the 4 for 8
they're not they naturally have one
coordinate so the uncompressed form is
actually at the short form so we're only
allowing one form for each group if it
turned out to be the case that people
were really been at a shape that P 256
was taking up poison of our space we
defined P 256 compressed and call it the
uncompressed format nobody seems to care
about this so the basic design basic
design modality of the people learned
over the past I don't know 20 years
about how many things faster is to stop
being so stupid about what the server
knows so if you look at one point if you
look at one point to basically the
client assumes is nothing on the server
capabilities whatsoever and that means
that you look you lose basically the
clients first messages and she's an
advertisement and you learn nothing
indeed and you spend that first round
trip largely lured in the server's
public key and so there's a whole long
strain of work going back to fast track
and then snap start and stuff like that
about how to optimize these exchanges if
you believe that this client knows that
the server's parameters are in any way
and there are two things the client
might have you might have specific
knowledge and we have general knowledge
and tell us one point three days
advantage of both and so in order to
make the general knowledge problem
better
we try to narrowly constrain the range
of options where servers might actually
have so we only have a very small number
of different groups on and we only have
diffie-hellman or I looked at cryptic
ailment and this means the client can
make a pretty good guess over the
server's capable of doing in particular
if the client generates the
diffie-hellman share and one of two
basic popular groups they're probably
the server will accept extraordinarily
high and so basically the two groups are
most likely the case RP 256 and two five
five one nine so what this means is the
client can in his initial handshake
won't for you to offer the server to
feel measure and can actually offer more
than one but I just joined here as one
and so he picks 256 and you offers the
server diffie-hellman share and this
means that the server can start
encrypting way away
because a server can generate only
diffie-hellman share and start
encrypting under the shared key way to
light so this allows you to shave
officing a round trip off the handshake
immediately and also the property that
basically everything the server sends
past the initial difficulty share is
encrypted which obviously is attractive
if you want to because part of our goal
script where the handshake one in a
group that a group that either on
general knowledge you think everybody
supports which is probably creativity
sex or two 509 or the last thing the
server used review if you remember on so
there's a way there's a there's a way if
you guess wrong there's a way to deal
with it so it doesn't doesn't just bail
there's no way on obviously obviously i
the if you don't have any information at
the service capabilities there's no way
to do better than this basically
unfortunately so this looks this looks
large and like this is little
rearrangement the 1.2 handshake largely
um but basically by having the client
speak first so it used to be that in 1.2
in diffie-hellman the client the server
side his diffie-hellman sharing his
first master but the clients to be able
to share didn't go into all his third
message and now you're just basically
moved everything up by one so you will
call at the target the target we're
looking for performance was that the
client experience of one round-trip
books one more tip exchange and the
server experience we didn't say the
server but the server now is a zero
round-trip exchange basically cuz server
because are speaking right away now the
server doesn't know who's talking to of
course but there plenty of times and the
server actually wants to say something
even though there's no he's talking to
so a good example would be if your T
sub-2 has a settings frame the basically
says these are the properties I'd like
you to use connection the server can
send out right away the earthing desert
can do optimistically on there were
still work at the details is HTTP has a
thing called server push where the
server can say in case you wanted to ask
for this request later here's the data
and so um it's pretty plausible if the
client comes in and the client looks
that's naive the client probably wants
index that HTML or he wants that vikon
deco and so you could probably push
either of those down at this point so
you say you say some arm trips um so and
the client basically getting the client
sends his finished Mac at the end and
and he gets to say in his application
eight at the same time so the client
basic experience is one round trip
handshake at this point so as I said
this is all diffie-hellman it's amazing
much simpler to assume it's Tiffin
because then we don't think about what
happens if there was if it's the
server's public key being carried in
this but not that but not the clients
sure so you might very well want to do
client authentication the client
vindication looks about the way you
expect namely in the server second
flight the server sends us different
requests which is basically please send
me a sort and then the client basically
said it's a certificate and things are
red or new obviously his certificate and
a signature over the handshake at this
point so you're still the same one right
trip exchange but you'll notice that the
client certificate in cryptid so the
privacy properties here about what you
expect namely that the server
certificate isn't cryptic as passive
attackers which is a some value in
non-web context perhaps not as much a
web contest because you can just illicit
the certificate yourself but the client
certificate encrypted against two active
attacker score the client validates a
server assert prior to sending his own
certificate so this is already removed
one of the reasons to renegotiation
which is pressing a client certificate
at the same time as you improve
performance someone um it's worth noting
that this is effectively on signal on by
park or checked on I it took us quite a
lot of notice that by the way um because
on the messages were kind of a funny
order and and we said and in particular
it used to be the certificate request
came between the certificate and the
signature and I was like and suddenly
like Karthik was staring at this and
he's like this is just Sigma like then
we start doing diagrams so so as I say
the client in German like a pretty good
guess of what the server's groups are
especially because they're only a few
but it's possible its clients wrong and
the most common thing with a client say
things took so much P 256 but the server
has a much higher security guarantee
it's probably not much point if you if
you have to 256 groups spot as possible
for the server support both and so if
there are two groups of a criminal
strength and the client offers you one
the server probably should just pick it
but if you want a higher security
guarantee and basically the server just
says look I see I see you give me a few
to the six but I wish you'd give me P
384 so please come back with P 3 2 for
the client says the same thing so this
is unfortunate and shouldn't happen very
often because this is showing up around
trip but we given that on as I say
clients are beginning to pick up more
and more server specific knowledge for
things like HSTs HP KP on and cookies so
especially on the web it's very common
for the for the client to talk to the
server before and know in service
properties are also to clanking memorize
this stuff yeah okay oh honey yes so
this is for protocol engineering reasons
it turns out on okay this in a second so
on the in TLS it doesn't really matter
but in DTLS it's very nice to have a
situation where the server can force you
to go away and not to keep any state
because you're asking earlier about boss
attacks one very common anti-dust
measure is for the server to say I'm
gonna give you a random value and please
come back and prove to me how that
random value it does demonstrating that
you're at the IP address you claim to be
and so on and so for for stream
protocols like TLS what I see CPA
doesn't help very much because they have
their own mechanism but if you're doing
TTC be fast open or you're doing DTLS
over UDP then you'd like to be able to
do this rejection mechanism without
having on without having the server have
to keep any state whatsoever and I know
that doesn't sound like an answer the
question but it's come get in there and
the so the issue is we wanted we wanted
to harmonize these mechanisms through
the same mechanism back they could do
the same thing and so on just reading to
have like anymore protocol messages and
it turns out so the server has to find
some way to maintain the on to maintain
the state that of right and a first to
mention there desiderata which is we're
very concerned about downgrade attacks
in this exchange here because what
happens if I offer P 256 and the server
says well come back with like you know P
what people in sixty right and so we
don't want a lot of downgrade attacks
and so the standard way to print
downgrade attacks on TLS is to continue
the handshake cache to the entire
exchange here right and so it turns out
that for protocol engineering reasons
like I talked about in more detail
offline on if you basically echo if you
basically only add to the thing you sent
it makes it easier to fit it is easier
to keep the state floating around which
may not sound very convincing by be have
adroit out the the basic observation is
that the client the server can basically
just look at look at the handshake and
say well the last thing and list must've
been the name is added and then in the
back estate we actually have two
mechanisms were discussing one of which
is there's someone in which involves
actually offloading it into a cookie but
we'd like to retain both and having
having this makes it easier okay so the
that's say you get to one roundtrip
there's no way to get to zero round
trips without doing a bunch of scoring
around and in particulars nobody has
their own trip so that having the client
talk to the server beforehand as far as
I know um if someone knows that he great
yeah please I mean the door
there are a few some side channels like
you say if the keys in the DNS or
something like that or you soon on IPE
but I mean but but generally speaking
with diffie-hellman you can't do this so
the basic observation and this goes back
at least as far as a snap start with
Langley and adieu goop but I think
actually even further is that the client
can cache the service to be own
parameters and use those for a future
handshake I've had to goes back as far
it goes back as far as fast-track um and
then you can send application date on
his very first flight by basically
piggybacking it on the initial client
hello but obvious that requires the
server to prime the client previously so
what does this look like I didn't tell
the priming handshake but it's actually
illustrate forward the client sends it
his client hello the server
configuration was they didn't a fire of
the key he's using which is some semi
static diffie-hellman key and then he
piggyback the application data on there
and I wish my arrows were further apart
and you'd be more obvious but that book
is he with the first arrow not the
second one on so that all works fine it
has a number of unfortunate drawbacks
which no one knows how to get around on
the first drawback is you don't get PFS
for this for flooded it and that's
obvious you can't get PFS because you're
using a sake we're about to hang on to
so you can't have PFF spores I'm getting
that's my slide so the the PFF thing
people willing to tolerate so first I
should say that I'm going to say a bunch
of bad things about this mechanism but
this mechanism is so valuable because
milliseconds or money that it's going in
anyway so TLS any replay is like the
standard any refund mechanism everybody
uses which is that each side provides
some random or these fresh value in
their handshake and you mix that into
the key material and then the keys must
be fresh obviously this cannot be
compatible with your TT because the like
the client has to speak first the
server's get a chance to send it up
sending anything on so the clients so
the clients the data says the client
does have any replay it is sent to the
server does not once you get past the
for once you get past this first message
to win read then you're fine but the
first measure is problematic so people
thought they knew how to solve this
problem everyone understood that some of
this problem acquired server-side state
no way around it and they're gonna pile
on that kind ISM suggested and people
thought they had an answer on so the
answer we were planning to use borrowed
on from snap start but also somewhat
more used in quick which is the server
keeps a list at every client-side ran in
this close any clients ever sent him on
is indexed by some server provided
context token series that'll keep them
forever and
the client parts a timestamp so
basically what the server does is he
looks up the context token and says
what's the earliest thing I know what
the latest thing I know about and then
is there a duplicate in here there are
duplicate he says it's new and that
seems like it's totally gonna work um it
doesn't it works fine if you basically
have a globally consistent store it does
not work if you have a store it can get
inconsistent so the story this is
actually a little entertaining in that
we um like I've been giving talks about
how we're gonna do this and saying we're
gonna still a mechanism snap start and
so we're in this chaos interim
like saying we're gonna sell the
mechanisms that start and today Oh Colin
Gilmore says well how does that start
work and I start explaining yet and he's
like what happens in this case and
Langley and I look and go like oh this
is not good um so so the basic so I'm
gonna give you contrived examples it's
easier to understand the non contrived
example the nan khatai example involves
multiple datacenters the Guittard
example looks like so one thing I should
mention is that the desired application
interface is that the zero RTC data be
transparent to the application so what I
mean by that is what happens when you
can after the server and the server has
forgotten all things to replay state
well what you want to do is you want to
take the death of your sentence your RTT
and send it in run RTT as the next
message because if you don't do that
then like your get got lost and this is
what you wanted was the home page that's
not gonna work for you so imagine saying
was slide it that's not it's fine as a
no side effects now imagine you have
side effects so the client connects to
the client connects to the server and he
said his client hello when he sends his
er TT like thing with buying something
and the server like on this earth and he
says an attacker as usual and the attack
I mean thinks he's talking to the server
and his servers credentials but the
attacker intercepts it because he's a
network attacker and he says it to the
server and the server processes the
purchase and sends back an
acknowledgement saying that everything
is good and the attacker eats that in
something attendance at the client um
and then the attacker tape and then
somehow the attacker managed to give us
a server to reboot and the server is now
lost all state including at state to
replay state that's okay because that's
okay because the we have a Peruvian
mechanism for recovering which the
server says listen I don't have any
answer you play state so send this
message again once you've incorporated
my my random value so the attacker
forces the reboot he retransmitted exact
same messages of the server the server
says no no I came to zero RTT and here's
like a here's like a random nonce and
the client now retransmits
his request at which point this response
is it twice so that's bad and it's easy
to convince yourself of you think about
a little bit that gave multiple data
centers you can do the same thing on
unless you're willing to basically
replicate invest you're willing to not
only replicate the in your play store
between the data centers but you're also
willing to basically say
if someone goes to the wrong data center
the one that doesn't have doesn't have
the master copy of the store that
basically you stole this connection
until you check the master copy and this
is not practical absolutely and
operationally you just back it out
having sent the guy a free return okay
so the scar is worth so yes that's
exactly correct on one thing to
recognize is that many browse in many
places in the browser stack if you said
forgetting about any this is roti
nonsense
you said you send your post request and
if you get like an rst the browser like
just sends it again cuz like because it
want stuff to happen um it's really true
forgets by the way anything that is
anything is ostensibly ident but in the
browser will totally we'll be happy to
retransmit and even things are not in a
particular or some circumstances were
also retransmitted this happens all the
way up another stack and by the way even
the browser's are we transmit the next
thing that happens is the user goes what
the heck it is the button again so right
so this isn't great but it's not like
it's not clear how bad it is actually on
it's not good don't get me wrong the so
where do things end up as I say the real
problem is multiple distribute data
centers and on the final resolution was
basically there was this very fancy
mechanism quickness now it's hard to try
to solve this problem and the bezel
loosen the until it's working group
after long discussion and also when you
talk to Google what they're gonna quit
cuz I believe is not even try anymore
basically say there's a special
mechanism that sends your RTT data only
sends stuff is ad impotent there and
don't try and if you don't do that like
it's on you and on so obviously this is
not safe to have on my default it has to
be a special API everybody agrees on
this but it's simply too valuable
function to not have there already were
pick this up online to if you a solution
this problem I'm extremely happy we
thought
pretty hard but doesn't mean we explore
everything on I will say that the the
the the configuration IDs do have data
center attachments to them
that's not works at all so tell us so
one thing is TLS is for a long time
supported a pre-shared key mode which
largely was used for like IOT type
applications where you couldn't afford
public key crypto at all or also
applications where they could afford
public key crypto but they couldn't
afford certificates well they couldn't
deploy them and see how like a password
whose job or even a long key Java was to
bootstrap off the connection for you so
sometimes you'd use it with
diffie-hellman and Sons use about 2 P
Hellman so some rule in the way it
became clear that PS k in resumption
we're like really really similar they
basically had like a long term key out
long term symmetric key and all you need
to do was like reboot the connection
with that and so TLS is basically fills
one way through is basically removing
resumption entirely and replacing it
only with PS k plus a new plus and plus
a mechanism for the server to space it
to send you a label for the existing
existing master secret
so basically way this works is exactly
like in ordinary tailless 1.2 tick on
ticket resumption the server sends you
here is a label and please the taxes
label the key we just negotiated and
then you can use that label 4ps Kate
negotiation instead so that has a nice
advantage of merging some stuff on so I
like this diagram this like is more
complicated looking this is less
complicated looking actually is TLS
everyone likes to take every individual
thing but its own message so like many
of these messages like I only have a
small thing in them but like they're
like
vertically massive so this is the
unified flow to re room for like like
all tails 1.3 um so the stuff at the top
is is the client holo with the 0tt the
stuff on the right is the service I can
flow and something left is a cycle i and
ii flow and as you can see we sort of
decorated the stuff with um with the
Sigma with the Sigma sections that shows
authentication because um I guess that
one's wrong so the when you look at a
diagram like that and you start it for
long enough you can convince yourself
that we can have one unified FN ocation
logic rather than a pile of different
indications lodgest attached together
and this reservation on I think probably
starts with it with crotch
Hajduk we who suggested this thing
called opt LS which is basically a
generalization of the sort of this sort
of 0 1 R T t0 TT on defueling framework
on and so basically the idea is you have
to input keys one of which is the
long-term input key which corresponds to
the statics the statics diffie-hellman
exchange you would do for 0 TT and one
of which is the short the sort of the
ephemeral key which corresponds the
ephemeral to fail in exchange and then
you put them all for the same key
derivation diagram and that gives you
all the key all the key neutral out now
in different modes you might have
different settings for which these keys
are so in PSK for instance both these
keys of the pre-shared key but there's a
single authentication logic for all on
and I think I think I think Hugo Hugo
and hoteth publish that publish to graph
their paper on the tails mamillus
recently on so you get a key duration
schedule it looks kind of like this with
the ephemeral secret in the status
secret and a bunch of each KD FS and
then producing these keys at the very
end so I guess I have yeah couple more
things to cover the I just said we
removed renegotiation which made
everybody sad and we really thought we
were gonna get away with nothing here
like all I got nothing burger in the
slot and Microsoft showed up and they
said we have all these applications
where people want to do client on
occasion after the handshake is over and
exactly the setting I told you we have a
website that's partially secure and
partially insecure and like we cannot
cut over like four it's a huge burden
for us to cover tale some point three
without cutting over this over as well
and in fact it's such a burden the HTTP
tube and renegotiation would TLS 1.2 and
I'm having to stuff it back in again
because it was so just a fallen to have
this feature on so a bunch of thought
went into this and again thought trying
to simplify the logic as much as we
could and the basic plan that sort of
becomes immediately apparent is that the
client in the server can send the
certificate request any part of the
handshake and elicits nothing but this
authentication block namely the
certificate this an insurer on the Mac
which if you recall the Sigma paper is
exactly what you use for authentication
ever or in Sigma on and if you think and
in the way this works is that the
signature signs the hand should
transcript the plus the certificate in
the max and the Mac max the
everything there plus the signature on
that's not the only way to do the good
Sigma composition but it's problem on
this piece of stolen derp a little bit
hairy development and it hasn't made in
specification and midway through this
process as people were looking at it um
so this team out of bro Holloway in
Oxford asked the question of what
happens if you combine pre-shared keys
and post handshake client authentication
and so this is something we always
wanted to work but we weren't quite sure
how to make it work and so it hadn't
made it in the specification yet um but
it's a you obviously want to work
because you if you have resume sessions
you want to build a decline if the
vacation afterwards and so again if your
specification it's like not in the
specification for something we always
have in the back of our heads and so if
you take the naive version of doing this
and you do it just said before which is
you add the certificate it's a very
quick request and this indication block
and you do it in PSK you run into some
problems on so this comes out of a
really quite nice analysis these guys
did with a formal tool called tamarin
and so there's this there's a set up
phase where the on the attacker
basically you connect the attacker and
the entire cache to the server and they
did a handshake and the server gives you
this key label the session ticket and
then the attacker forwards you exactly
the same key label but for his for his
keys they're two different keys in the
left right we've already solve that
problem for different keys
but the key levels the same there's
nothing stopping him doing that and so
then what happens is you can actually
attacker and you do a new resumed
handshake and the Tigers deserver to the
new resumed handshake and again they're
totally theirs and again these are
separate keys because the keys are
separate because it because we've
already solve that problem and the
attack and the server um does this
different request and then you forward
the signature over the before the sit
the fennec ation signature over the
system right and the attack remember has
both keys even though keys are different
and so for structural reasons the
signatures in the current version of TLS
do not cover the handshake max and the
reason that committee handshake max is
because we were trying to actually make
the logic of the 1rt teaser to
decomposition work better
and on and it turned out to be a hassle
to do that so I got the one or T the the
one RT t the saris one RT t non-client
up inclined off wrong what works better
on and so when we when we actually sat
down and designed this PR 163 16 the
post and check authentication stuff we
put that back in we find a way to find a
way to keep it in that actually made the
system even cleaner on but if you don't
do that then we have an attack here on
because the attack because if you're not
signing if you're not sign if you're not
signing anything just drive from the
drive from the from the master key then
you can just forward the fennec Asian
Santa so problem averted the on so you
know we were very happy to see that see
this result for two reasons one because
it reinforced that the thing with the
direction we were planning to go in was
the right direction and second because
it meant that people actually were doing
some really substantial work on doing
formal analysis of TLS 1 3 2 in order to
find this on so they they believe they
have a pretty complete model at this
point in the tamron theorem prover so
really big thanks to this group for
finding this and and really nice really
a sketch because I say reinforce to the
direction that we decided to go okay
right so the last thing I wanna talk
about is on defenses against traffic
analysis so tales 1.2 has extremely
limited traffic analysis defenses which
is to say basically none the on the
content type out which I mean the kind
of message you're sending whether it's
handshake or a load of data is in the
clear and the there's a provision for
padding or the packet length but only
for block ciphers
and only a very small amount of padding
up to 255 objects and a practical matter
people tend to use minimal padding on
there's no padding at all in the stream
or AED mode so you can compute meet
given the type of the cipher you need
immediately how long natural messin must
have been so as I said people's opinion
about what you should do here have moved
on since what this was designed and so
there's a lot of pressure to do
something here on the two main things
that happened are one adding on meeting
could be the content type so you can't
see what I message is so it is for
example
in this exchange up here you wouldn't be
able to tell there's nothing another
authentication handshake happening
unless you did like packet size analysis
and in order to print packet size
analysis we're allowing arbitrary
amounts of padding um much like
compression no one knows how to do
generic padding that works we know how
to add the padding we still know how big
the padding on it be so if the
applications jobs with the padding all
we do is mechanism the design here is
quite clever
I'm not mine it's guy named Martin
Thompson and cooperation madam Langley
the old TLS pilled like this so the new
tales payload has exactly the same by
the way header because everybody's
terrified if we screw this header and
there's always middle boxes which we'd
like to lengthen in the wrong place and
we'll choke so so far we're not gonna
screw the header but we did we took the
content-type
and we made the outer content tape fix
to the inner content type is the real
content type and it goes at the end and
the reason it goes at the end it is two
reasons first because it means that when
you decrypt you don't have too many
light one and when you encrypt don't
even copy everything right one and the
second is what's it if we pad at the end
with zeros and we promise the content
type will never never be 0 then you can
slip the padding loss by using really
the right and counting left word on and
that's really nice because it means that
because it means that the client does
not the receivers last to know whether
padding is in use so first of all you
can have you can have no padding at all
and doesn't have any impact on on the
record size on C so all other structures
we had have like a padding length and
that always chewed up one byte and that
pissed people off because they were like
we don't want to we don't want to burn a
Piton padding if we don't want padding
which almost nobody does on and and so
this allows you to basically strip it
off quite easily on which is quite
clever and I can say it's clever because
it wasn't me I guess I did it one more
thing the other sort privacy property
and this is sort of more work in
progress here is the single server name
indication so say you want to be like
Amazon and you want to have like a pile
of servers all on the same piece of
hardware so each server may have its own
certificate so you know you have knock
use calm and hidden calm and then this
and they have different certificates so
when the clip and obviously when the
client connects to you you've got to
prove either right guy who the wrong guy
he's gonna hopefully disconnect
so the old-school way is give you
servers on my own IP address and that
isn't really working out very well with
this whole like I Peters exhaustion
thing believe it or not it's actually
people buy and Lords have to do and the
reason is that first there are two very
unfortunate implementations which should
not do the right thing on the right
thing is this thing called server name
indication which is an extension in the
client hello this says I would like to
talk to fubar calm
unfortunately Android 2.2 and Windows XP
shipped without server name indication
and what that means is that if you want
to run a system that is accessible to
everybody in the internet you have to
have your own IP address for everything
and even now that's a really quite such
different fashion of people's traffic on
but they're there now we're starting to
beat there now we're starting to be
sites which hosting services would say
look we're going to offer you two tiers
you can have the your own IP tier which
is expensive and you can have the sni
only tier if you don't care about
Android - - and that's cheap and so
people are trying to move towards this
and it's a required feature furtillo 0.3
and never once before so unfortunately
yes there's still Asian you know if
you're doing something like you know say
Google box right where you can't really
want to like a minute little minute a
but anyway I mean you can build things
that like if you're the only target
desktop basically you say well I don't
care um I said XP but basically XP is
the XP browser actually largely
dominated by Firefox or Chrome so it's
not like and those guys do SMI just fine
so it's only like I either doesn't hear
us and I and frankly if using that
version of ie
you're gonna have a bad day no matter
what the unfortunate thing is
S&I consists of identity so we had all
this trouble to occur if the server
certificate and now the enemy's being
big suddenly sucks I mean I used to hide
the s tonight and the application which
people keep pointing out is anti
censorship so you have it's pretty
common for instance to have sites which
are innocuous co-located with sites
which are not innocuous so say you have
you know you have your hidden site and
it's on github
get up pages right
sitting next to Nasik stuff that no
sense are care sir you talk to and the
sensor doesn't want to block it up
entirely or is on Google App Engine they
want to block Google App Engine entirely
but it's they can look at the US and all
I think it's a well this is the this is
the thing I want to censor this thing I
want so be very nice to figure out how
to encrypt at the working we're still
struggling with this little feature the
difficulty the general idea the only
thing makes any sense is to stuff that
information somewhere in zero and the
zero key data and basically say well um
and base and basically say that if you
can't do the rtt you you know falling
back in your sense ripple and that's
just the way life is and so the typical
thing would do is they you'd have a
bogus us and I in the in the in the
public header and you have somewhere in
the in the encrypted data you have the
real loss and I and if you care to
somebody and they've forgotten and
they've forgotten the server the key
material used for decrypting these your
QC data then they basically could that
you get whatever the poll certificate is
and that's probably wrong are you
choking yep and then you have to live
with it but there lots of settings
that's plausible in particular if you
know that sites a cover site then you
can then what happens you can to the
cover site and then you elicit from how
you lose it from them their news or to
kiki-annie reconnect so the general idea
is seem straightforward the details will
look complicated and the details largely
have to do with exactly how much
violence were prepared do the rest of
TLS in order to accommodate this feature
there are on there there are some there
are some very simple designs and oh
there's a three-way trade-off which is
how much we to keep TLS the way it is on
how good a job it does and how much
effort it is to do to do encrypted else
and I over an unencrypted SNI so some
very nice designs which are don't do any
change to tell us whatsoever basically
and and work fine but have the
consequence I can draw one for you later
on but at the consequence that it's a
lot more work through encrypted sni than
not occur to us and I and so part of the
value proposition we've been nice to
have a situation where sites
automatically doing encrypted us and I
if they could and it's not clear we can
get that so we're still struggling that
tension
this is my last time okay so where do
things stand now one Kurt this is an
idea like I said we're currently in
draft ten on almost every major issue
has at least original resolution but
with the exception of this I'm Curtis on
issue um we're really hoping the script
doesn't I think without changing much
else so it doesn't doesn't change impact
very much um we're expecting to have
drafts on the time not spending here is
time I'm not writing so on but I'm
expecting to have by the end of the
month basically all the things you're
all resolutions for in the draft so
we'll have a fairly complete draft by
then we're already starting to see
formal models emerging which is great um
and there's this workshop that is being
held in February
hosted by collectivity SS with the
program chairs I think Matt green and
Kenny Patterson to basically get like a
final readout on what people think about
this protocol before we deploy it
hopefully which we nice we're trying
this time to like actually have a bunch
of analysis prior to deployment on and
um implementations are starting to
emerge I'm working the firefights
implementation now there's no other
people working on that input Asian other
other engines um we'll probably first we
expect to have this in some sort of
alpha version of Firefox beliefs by end
of year though probably won't be on by
default and we expect to be an ITF lost
call sometime in q1 like you want maybe
q2 with the standard publish later in
2016 I yes they're probably they're
gonna they're gonna probably follow us
but yeah we talk to them we don't have
it we don't date yet um if you want
follows work they're way way to do this
is best second last slide apologize is
there's an ITF mailing list obviously on
we're doing this new thing we do almost
all our work in github so you can just
like go to github and see all the pro
changes and the currency of the draft so
and if you find stuff it is small or big
I guess you said let's pull requests
instead of having to write us some long
email message so please do contribute
now I'm done
alliances protocols for flying over NTSC
look like they will fit in very nicely
here we have met we're just we're just
meeting with father guys today so there
basically are two current modalities for
doing climate medication via sorry we
put I mean there's lots of modalities
dedication with reasonable tokens of
race cons on but the two basic
modalities between public key based plan
authentication are wondering the TLS
layer and the second doing the
application layer and so the on the
application layer ones are either Fido
so Fido is not on or they're on what's
called token binding which is also which
is also cuz I don't see much of the same
crew Soto combining is about boosting
boosting cookies and Feitosa using
tokens but they're all kind of the same
thing there's something that the client
signs on in Fido so in token binding is
extremely like post-tensioned client
authentication which is to say you're
signing some stuff that came out of the
TLS connection Fido you sign the domain
rather than the token binding will sign
something that is if there's a version
photo TLS connection and that's what
will not be portable between TLS
connections so the the test the metal
test you should have is imagine the
client certificate validation libraries
completely busted on what is the impact
on the system right and so what Chile's
client off on the design criteria line
you would hope to have is even if the
client that sort of your validation
library is totally busted that would not
allow you to impersonate the client and
Fido does not that property but token
binding does
it's my understand
so if you're signing over the
certificate right then even if you
completely fail to validate this
certificate is never the case the server
will traffic will check it and will and
will fail any light on it does not true
I'd be interested in hearing about it
looks it should be in HTTP - yes the
traffic is encrypted so I was wondering
when you say you're not you've taken out
compression from TLS 1.3 does that mean
even a web page HTML web page wouldn't
be compressed when it's sent down from
the server no on the eye
so TLS had a need of compression
mechanism and that you can negotiate in
tell us that we transparent the
application that's what we're moving if
there's an application which has own
compression that's always fine I mean
it's right that will continue to
function that we don't always function
it may or may not be fine we're used on
the TLS compression yeah the breach
attack if you have data from two
separate prominences that are being
compressed by the same compression
algorithm you were at risk right even
Kilson have it so I mean imagine you put
some layer and as you staple a
compression layer on top of TLS between
TLS HTTP you'll be back and even the
same problems you have with TLS
compression so it's not the case so yes
it I don't mean to say it's fine to do
this I need to say that it shouldn't we
will that we're not breaking you you're
yours
you're no vote no worse off than you
were before it to anything and as I say
you should be due to there's at least
two HTTP compression mechanisms which
continue to be active
one is the odd one is when is this
header compression mechanism which was
specifically added and the other is
there a bunch of payload compression
mechanisms like GZ outputs continue to
be functional yeah we have known put it
I mean a cb2 does not really know much
about TLS it's just a substrate
you